okay hello everyone
welcome back to another episode of
science and technology q a
for kids and others and i see
a few questions that were left over from
last
time which i will start off looking at
um
let's see i thought i had answered some
of these before
okay there's a question here from
alexander
about quantum computers and um
commenting that he's noticed that i've
said a number of times that i don't
think quantum computers are going to
work
um but uh nevertheless he reads
accounts that say a quantum computer
with such and such a number of qubits
has been created
okay let's talk about what quantum
computers are
what might work about them what qubits
are what might not work
and so on um
the uh um
so okay first of all how do ordinary
computers work
well so at some fundamental level
ordinary computers
are dealing with binary bits
places where there either is a piece of
electric charge or there isn't
and usually all current computers work
using
uh semiconductors and basically what's
happening
is they're on on a cpu chip there might
be a billion
different little tiny transistors and
each transistor has these little
places where there's a little tiny
amount of charge it's maybe
thousand electrons uh per bit and if the
electrons are there in a particular
place
then that means that the computer says
that particular bit is a one
and if they're not there it means that
particular bit is a zero
and then when that turns into uh
what is the data that represents
i don't know something on my screen
let's say my screen might have um
uh 5 million bytes
of information that's and byte is eight
bits
so that's uh 40 million uh bits of
information 40 million places
somewhere on my cpu chip where there is
some uh
actually it'd probably be in a
co-processor but basically in the in the
in the in the microprocessor in my
computer there'll be a place where i'm
storing
the information that um uh there'll be
this little
clump of 100 000 electrons maybe maybe a
little bit less these days
that represent whether that pixel on my
screen
has is a one or a zero and
when the computer is computing things
what's happening is
there will be these um these packets
of uh clumps of electrons are being sort
of shoveled
through um these these gates where it'll
be like
if there were electrons in this place
but not in this place there may be
electrons in this place
and that would be an example of one of
the sort of fundamental
operations uh well
the most fundamental operation on most
computers is the nand operation that
says
if there are not electrons in either of
these two places
then make electrons be in this place and
you might think how can you build up
everything a computer does from just
that one operation
but that's one of the really neat things
that's been figured out through
through lots of work in logic and
mathematical logic and computation
that it's possible to just take that one
simple operation
first of all and and go from nand to all
the ands and ors and knots
and then go from the ends and ors and
knots to the whole operation of a
universal computer
that's all it takes so that's how an
ordinary computer it's just shoveling
around these
these blocks of electrons and so on with
definite things
supposed to be happening so you know the
electrons the the
lump of electrons two lambs electrons
are there
then there won't be a lump of electrons
there at the next
um at the next moment and the next
moment is usually most computers have a
a central clock
maybe in modern times it might go uh at
a rate of maybe two billion
uh cycles per second where two billion
times a second
it says okay electrons go to the next
thing you're supposed to do
and that so every time that every ev at
every
uh sort of tick of the clock um you're
doing these different operations
but the way an ordinary computer works
is doing definite operations
it's like the electrons here and there
okay make electrons
not be there at the next at the next
tick of the clock
okay the idea of a quantum computer
is to make use of quantum mechanics to
say
well we don't have just one definite
thing happening
we have and this is sort of the big idea
of quantum mechanics which is kind of
the mechanics that
governs very small things like
individual electrons and so on
instead of having uh these big lumps of
electrons which are going to do definite
things
just make it be the case that uh
you're sort of leading the quantum
system to to do many possible things
and the quantum system can do those
things in parallel
and the way quantum mechanics works it's
sort of following all these different
possible paths
of of of things that could happen and
only when
the the you sort of finished it's
finished following all those paths and
we say well what actually happened
we make a measurement of what happened
then somehow
it has to kind of decide what really
happened and
give a definite result and quantum
mechanics it's sort of a mysterious
thing how this all works it's something
we've made a lot of progress
recently in figuring out in the sort of
this new approach to fundamental theory
of physics
a lot of a lot of progress and really
understanding how quantum mechanics
works
let me give you a sort of an indication
of how quantum mechanics works
that's sort of a picture so imagine the
game tic-tac-toe
so you are you know playing this game
and you have the x's and the o's
and uh you start off in some particular
way and um
there are many different possible games
that could be followed there many
different places the x and the o can be
put down
but at the end either the x wins or the
o wins
and this is a little bit of a how
quantum mechanics works actually the
mathematics of how that works
seems to be very closely analogous that
in a sense you're saying we're going to
start these things off and there are
many possibilities for what can happen
but in the end there's a definite result
one thing wins the other thing wins
the electron is either there or it's not
there but
in the middle you don't really know what
happened and what what happens
uh in in sort of a quantum version of
tic-tac-toe
instead of it being a definite sequence
of moves that are taken in a sense all
possible moves are being taken
and only at the end do you find out
whether whether
uh the x1 or the or the one
um and so so that's kind of the idea is
that is that you follow
all these paths in parallel um and
somehow the universe
is doing that all the time at a small
scale and that's what quantum mechanics
really is
now um the idea of quantum computers is
to be able to take advantage of all that
all those parallel things that can go on
to be able to do
many different computations in parallel
and only at the end
when you're like searching for something
you can say let's try all these
different cases
and if one of them is the finds what
you're looking for
then make that be the result but you can
instead of
trying to do the search by saying try
this then try this then try this then
try this then try this
the idea is do all those searches in
parallel and that's something that the
physics of quantum mechanics says you
should be able to do
okay here's the basic problem from a
theoretical point of view which is
yes the physics of quantum mechanics
says
you can uh you can do all these things
in parallel
they will happen in parallel but the
problem is when you want to figure out
what happened when you want to do the
measurement
there's a whole process that one has to
go through in figuring out
how to go from the set of parallel
things that could have happened
to a definite thing that that is sort of
what actually happened
and that process of measuring things is
something that hasn't been well
understood
and in fact in the last hundred years or
so since quantum mechanics was invented
investment about 100 years ago now um
the uh this process of measurement is
always something a bit mysterious most
calculations that you do
about quantum mechanics about the
properties of atoms and things like that
they don't really it doesn't really
matter
how this measurement process works but
when you actually try to build a quantum
computer
it really matters that the quantum
computer has to do this measurement has
to say
what was that final answer everything
was computed in parallel but then
what was the actual answer and what
seems to be the case and what we've
discovered is that that process of doing
measurement is actually quite difficult
um and while the quantum mechanics gives
you this opportunity to have all these
things
be done in parallel getting from the
point where you have all these things
that happen in parallel
down to oh and a definite thing happened
that requires a whole bunch of
computation
and it seems like that computation is at
least
as difficult as what you gain
from not having to go through and
sequentially do everything and being
able to work in parallel
now i mentioned how classical computers
work
and uh i talked about these these bits
and so on and
like a typical computer these days might
have i don't know um
let's say i don't know 64 gigabytes of
memory
that means um uh
can i do the math in my head here 128
256
512. yes that means um uh 512 billion
bits of of uh of memory
okay so 512 billion that's a
half a trillion bits so in quantum
mechanics
once trying to set things up so that one
can have
information stored at the level of
in these so-called qubits where a qubit
is something that isn't a it's always a
one or it's always a zero
it's something where it is something
where in that idea of sort of all these
parallel possibilities
a cubit can kind of participate in that
parallelism the qubit can be
well it's a one in some situations but
it's a zero in other situations all
happening in parallel
that's what a qubit is and people have
been trying to build computers with
lots of qubits where in the case of
remember we have
half a trillion bits in your average
computer
maybe these days a classical computer
um people are like we managed to get 10
qubits
in our quantum computer that's the kind
of thing one's doing there
now those 10 qubits if they really
worked according to plan
they might be quite powerful because
those 10 qubits actually can represent
what one's dealing with is not definite
ones and zeros but sort of all possible
combinations of ones and zeros so in 10
qubits that be 1024 two to the ten
possible combinations
so people have different schemes for
making qubits sometimes they're made out
of superconducting
uh so-called josephson junctions which
are
things that use the quantization of
magnetism and
superconducting devices um sometimes
they're made of
um using uh various kinds of um
cavities um microwave cavities sometimes
they're made using
using features of individual photons of
light there are a variety of different
technologies
for trying to make these these kinds of
qubits and in practice when people
set up these computers they uh
they are doing they may be going to lots
of trouble
to measure the results they don't really
know
how much effort it takes to measure the
results what they do know
is that after a certain amount of time
there's this phenomenon called
decoherence that happens
that goes from sort of the quantum
effect
to oh it doesn't really it isn't really
operating in a quantum way anymore
and that happens fairly quickly in many
of these computers and that's sort of a
trade-off between doing that and
measurement and so on
and it's a bit unclear sort of what the
resource use really is
in these computers and that's the big
issue is from at least a theoretical
point of view
is it the case that you can sort of get
advantage from having the physics of
quantum mechanics operate
and you don't lose that advantage
through all of the stuff about how you
measure the results and the decoherence
and all this kind of thing
one doesn't know that yet and when the
certainly doesn't know that for sort of
the case of most interest which is
lots of qubits really difficult
computations
my guess is it's not going to work out
from a theoretical point of view
although in practice representing bits
of information using for example
sort of single electrons or single
amounts of quantized magnetic flux
these kinds of things that may be super
efficient relative to our current scheme
of use a hundred thousand electrons per
bit
and so the physics of what's going on
may be highly interesting
even though the kind of theoretical
advantage of oh quantum mechanics makes
everything work in parallel
may not pan out um so that's kind of a
the
the story i think of of um of kind of
the um
uh what what these qubits are and um
kind of the picture of of how quantum
computers might might work
um and there are only very specific
kinds of computations that people
imagine
might be be able to be done sort of more
efficiently in a quantum computer than
an ordinary computer it's been a
surprisingly small set of computations
basically three
um uh factoring integers doing certain
kinds of searches
and simulating actual systems that
operate according to quantum mechanics
there's only three i think which have
been uh seriously considered there and
so
it's surprising that in in the course of
many years there haven't been
other kinds of computations that one can
sort of even theoretically say
could be much more efficiently done on a
quantum computer
um i should say sort of footnote to this
um
there are some different kinds of things
that get the brand of quantum computer
the thing i've been talking about are
so-called quantum circuits
um there's a different approach
which is more like a quantum spin glass
and maybe i can talk about that another
time people are interested that's kind
of not the
not the quite mainstream way of um
of doing quantum computing all right
let's see there's a question from uh
martian lemon how do we know there are
more than three dimensions
so in our physical universe so far as we
can tell
it's pretty close to there just being
three dimensions just move around and
you know
left right front back up down
the question of whether as a theoretical
matter
doing mathematics you can imagine
different numbers of dimensions
five dimensions 15 dimensions even three
and a half dimensions
that's a different question it's not too
hard to understand that let me give you
an example i'm
i'm going to say it in words it'd be
easier if i used a computer but i think
i could say it in words
let's say you draw a picture of a square
you've got four points
you join them up okay let's say you draw
an outline of a cube
you've got eight points you join it up
in a cube
let's say you've just got two points you
can join them up in a kind of
one-dimensional thing just a line goes
from one point to the other
so you've got the one-dimensional thing
two points
the two-dimensional thing four points
joined in a in a
square the three-dimensional thing the
eight points
joined in a cube what happens if you
have 16 points
well there's a way of joining them so
that every point
is joined in that case to four neighbors
in the case of the cube it's joined to
three neighbors
in the case of the square it's joined to
two neighbors if you go to 16 points you
can join every point
to four neighbors and so then what
you'll get is this
kind of network that you can think of as
representing a four-dimensional cube
now if we make a picture of it we're
just making a picture where we have
projected the four-dimensional cube and
we're just seeing it in two dimensions
just like if we draw a cube on a piece
of paper we're taking a
three-dimensional object and showing it
in two dimensions
but you can do that perfectly well for a
four-dimensional object or a
five-dimensional object
or a ten-dimensional object and so on
and that's the sense in which one can
imagine other numbers of dimensions now
there's a question in physics
of whether maybe the physical universe
doesn't have
exactly three dimensions but maybe more
there's something that came out of the
uh thing called string theory which is
kind of a long-running theory that's had
a couple of different uh a couple of
different um sort of
runs and over the course of the last uh
uh 60 years or so
um and one of them it was kind of a
an idea for how sort of how gravity and
quantum mechanics and things should all
fit together and i had the problem that
when you worked out the math
the thing was horribly it just didn't
make sense
unless the number of dimensions of space
was either 26
or 10 and so that's like there's
something wrong with that
because our actual space plus time is
like three plus one dimensions
that's not ten or twenty six how do we
how do we understand this
um that was something where
mathematically the theory said oh it
should be in ten dimensions
um then there's sort of a question of
well could that actually be right
could it be that there are sort of uh
let's say
six other dimensions that are all rolled
up in little balls and we
aren't um sensitive to them to me that's
probably a sign that the theory wasn't
really
on the right track it's usually a bad
sign when one's theory
sort of says and there's something
should be true about the world and you
can plainly see it's not
um but uh the mathematics of string
theory is very elegant
and actually even relevant to the theory
that we're making
and so people sort of pressed forward
even despite that problem and found all
sorts of interesting mathematical
physics results
um let's see a question here
from etore uh
what is quantum tunneling
okay let's say
uh let's say you are trying to
roll a ball over a hill
you make the ball roll if it has and
then you have this hill
and the question is if the ball has
enough
uh momentum and enough kinetic energy
the ball will
kind of you know you can get it to kind
of let's say you're doing i don't know
let's say let's try and be mod and say
you're doing skateboarding or something
and you're going at a certain speed and
the question is can you get
over that hill based on the speed you're
going at if you're going fast enough
you'll just be able to you know you'll
have enough enough energy
and get to the top of the hill get to
the top of the hill it's all good and
you go down the other side
okay so that's kind of the view if you
have enough energy
you can get through this kind of you can
get over the hill
okay well there's this funny phenomenon
that happens
uh in quantum mechanics that even when
you don't have enough energy to get over
the hill
there is a slight chance that you might
get over the hill anyway
and um this is something that doesn't
happen for you know big people like
skateboarders so to speak but
it does happen for individual particles
uh like the kinds of particles that
exist like protons and neutrons and
and um uh particularly clumps of protons
and neutrons called alpha particles
that are actually helium nuclei two
protons two neutrons
um the question is can uh even when
there's this kind of barrier
to an alpha particle getting from one
place to another
is there can it can it do it and the
phenomenon of quantum tunneling
is well actually it depends on the on
the on the amount of energy you need to
get over the barrier
but if you are below the barrier even if
you're below the barrier
there's still a slight probability you
can get over that energy barrier
the the probability decreases
exponentially
with the amount of the with the size of
the barrier that means
if you if you um um
if you multiply if the if the uh
let's say every as you increase
the amount of energy just you know you
go
one to two to three to four to five
you're going down
by by uh by factors
of some constant so it might be ten
times less likely if the energy is
if the barrier is twice as high it might
be uh ten times less likely if it's
three times as high
it might be a hundred times less likely
and so on to get over the barrier
what is what actually happens in quantum
tunneling
we actually have an understanding of
that in our new theory of physics
um it's would take me a little bit to
explain how that works
essentially what what happens is that
the the instead of sort of going through
the physical space
that goes from one side of this barrier
to the other you're going through this
thing we call branchial space which is
the space of quantum states
and it's kind of an abstract abstract
space
and that's kind of what's happening in
quantum tunneling is that you're kind of
uh you're kind of getting from here to
there
not by going through physical space but
by going through this bronchial space
but it would take a bit more explanation
to to say how that works
now what's the significance of quantum
tunneling one of the pieces of
significance is
because of this exponential effect a
small change
in the in the potential barrier can make
a huge change in the chance that quantum
tunneling happens
that has a big effect on radioactivity
so radioactivity is the phenomenon where
an atomic nucleus
um uh becomes unstable uh so for example
um a very famous one is uranium-235
um it's uh uranium with 235 protons
neutrons in its nucleus uranium-235
kind of just spontaneously falls apart
the nucleus is not
those protons and neutrons are not bound
together strongly enough
and after a certain amount of time
uranium nucleus just self-destructs
well there are other nuclei that
fall apart by emitting an alpha particle
it means that two protons two neutrons
uh just sort of get thrown off from the
nucleus
and that's the mechanism for
radioactivity
one of the very surprising things is
that there are radioactive
elements that are alpha emitters that
have lifetimes
as short as uh a trillion
a trillionth of a second and as long as
a billion years huge range of different
kinds of lifetimes so
the lifetime is determined by what's the
chance what's the rate at which
these alpha particles get emitted from
the nucleus well
turns out that the the the basic
phenomenon of alpha decay
alpha radioactivity is related to
quantum tunneling
and that huge range of different
lifetimes is a reflection of this
exponential phenomenon that i was
telling you about before that even
though these different elements
just have a little bit different energy
barriers that
because quantum tunneling is an effect
that depends exponentially on the energy
barrier
the effect on the lifetime is is immense
and so it can range from a billion years
down to a trillionth of a second
that's kind of a little bit on on
quantum tunneling
um
let's see okay there's a question here
um
the question here from brian why is the
three-body problem so hard to solve
okay so first what is the three-body
problem
so imagine the sun
and the earth the force of gravity
holds the earth in its orbit earth goes
around in a nice orbit around the sun
and what was figured out back in the
time of kepler and newton back in the
1600s
is that the earth follows an ellipse
around the sun not quite a circle it's
very close to a circle but it's not
exactly a circle
it's an ellipse which is a like a circle
with two different radii in two
different directions
and it follows an ellipse with the sun
sort of the one focus of the ellipse
and there's a nice set of mathematical
formulas that describe that ellipse
and that's the two-body problem the sun
the earth
two bodies now the real situation a bit
more complicated but there's a good
idealization of that which is just this
two-body problem
okay what happens if we think about the
moon as well that's the
three-body problem because there's the
gravity of the sun
acting on the earth there's the gravity
of the earth acting on the moon
but there's also the gravity of the sun
acting on the moon
and the gravity of the moon acting on
the earth and all
these systems are all uh interacting
with each other
well it just turns out that the
mathematics of the three-body problem
is just a lot more complicated in the
mathematics of the two-body problem
how can we see that um
well let's see there are probably a few
facts
to say so in the two body problem um
first of all the the the path that's
followed is always an ellipse
whatever happens towards an ellipse
actually if the if the body escapes its
orbit
it can be a a parabola or a hyperbola
instead
but if it's in it's an orbit it's an
ellipse and that's it
um in the case of the three-body problem
there can be just all kinds of different
things that happen you see these
pictures of three body problems i made
plenty myself
where the you know one body comes in
that two other ones that are orbiting
and this third body
just comes around it looks like a big
scribble and it takes a really long time
even for it to
have a final outcome so the final
outcome might be let's say you've got a
binary star system
which is two stars orbiting each other
and another star comes in
and it comes near that binary star
system what's going to happen well one
thing could happen is it could capture
it it could end up in a ternary star
system
another thing could happen is it could
break that star system apart and all
three stars could go off to different
places
lots of different things could happen
one of the things you see when you
do simulations of this is that sometimes
these stars go around this really
complicated dance for a really long time
and you can't figure out what's going to
happen so one of the things that
that you can see is that the amount of
time if you say
i'm going to do my simulation and my
simulation is going to last
for the equivalent of a thousand years
um
in you know in the real life of the
stars so to speak
um the uh uh it may not be clear what's
going to happen after a thousand years
and say well
okay i'll wait a million years still
they're dancing around doing complicated
things
not clear what's going to happen so
that's one of the problems and that's
that's kind of one of the reasons that
so that leads to the possibility it's
like
if you're running a computer program and
somebody says to you what's this program
going to do
you say well i think it's supposed to do
this maybe it'll have a bug maybe it
won't do that
it's very easy to get a program where
it's very hard to foresee what the
program is going to do
and where really the only way you can
work out what the program is going to do
is by just running it and seeing what
happens
the three-body problem is probably an
example of something which works that
way which has a phenomenon i call
computational irreducibility
um which uh which causes that that
effect to occur now i should say that
one of the things that happened in the
late
um in the 1800s the solution of the
three-body problem was like
a top problem of mathematics and physics
was like that was the big prize can you
solve the three-body problem
and so people tried very hard to do that
and one of the things that they tried to
figure out is when you solve the two
body problem
the answer comes out in terms of
mathematical functions like sines and
cosines and also actually so-called
elliptic integrals
um but it's basically pretty civilized
things like at least the sines and
cosines
are things you'd learn about in in you
know a trigonometry class or something
like this
um and civilized kinds of things
sometimes equations you can write down
equations
and it can be really hard to solve those
equations and it may be the case that
you can't solve those equations
using anything that you already knew
about so for example
quadratic equations x squared minus 3x
plus 2 equals 0 or something
equations like that there's a formula
that says you know
x equals let's see if i remember the
quadratic formula minus b over 2a
plus square root of b squared minus 4ac
over
over 2
[Music]
uh over 2a
yes um sorry i had to actually work that
out
um the um in any case the um
uh that's just a formula for the
solution of any equation that involves
x squared and x something involving x
and a constant it's a formula in terms
of square roots that
that lets you solve it if you go up to
the equation x
cubed x times x times x etc what
value of x solves that there's also a
formula for that it's a big long
complicated formula it involves cube
roots
same thing for x to the fourth you can
write down big long formula that
involves fourth roots
okay what about when it's an x to the
five in there
people thought about that for a long
long time the the uh the case of the
cubic and the quartic they were solved
in the 1500s
and people up until the 1800s were
thinking can we solve the quintic
the the equation of a with x to the five
and nobody figured out how to do it
and eventually a young fellow named
alvares galwa came along
and basically proved sorry you just
can't do it you there isn't a formula
for the solution to a quintic involving
um
uh let's say uh fifth roots of things
and so on there's no
there's no algebraic formula for this
general solution to quintex
that was proved in the 1830s um then by
the
1880s 1890s the
similar result was proved for the
three-body problem that it's not
possible
to have um it's some the the official
term is algebraic integrals of the
motion
um that it isn't possible to basically
write down a solution for the three-body
problem
in terms of algebra type functions
if you if you want to write down the
solution of the three-body problem you
have to invent some new exotic kind of
mathematical function
to describe that solution and there's
not a guarantee that you can compute
what the values of those solutions are
much more efficient than by just running
the three-body problem
so that was the main result is that
there are no you can't solve it as an
algebraic thing
and it can take sort of as as long to
work out what happens
as it would to just run every step in
the evolution
um and that's uh probably let's see if i
could
gosh do i have any chance to be able to
sort of derive for you in real time the
fact that there are no algebraic
integrals of the motion for the three
body problem i think not
i think it's a it's a bit too
mathematically complicated
um but so that's a that's a response to
that
um
okay here's a question uh different kind
of question
oh boy we're getting so many of these
you guys are such interesting questions
all right this is a bit more of a
history question from parmenides
uh who is your favorite manhattan
project scientist
says i was reading about stanislaw ullam
did i ever meet him
yes i didn't i did know stan iwam um
okay first bit of background history so
for people who don't know it the
manhattan project was a big project done
in world war
ii um in the u.s um
the goal was to make an atomic bomb
which was successfully done in 1945
and was kind of a a great
sort of success of science to be able to
do that it went from
the discovery of radioactivity in um uh
in the in the 1910s i guess
to um to the realization that it was
possible to make
uh energy from from nuclear processes
um that sort of was was realized in
1930s 1940s
to then the idea you can make an atomic
bomb and then to actually
build one and it was built in a rather
small amount of time by what maybe three
four years
um uh by this uh it was sort of a large
collection of physicists who were
involved in doing this
um it was a project led by a person
called robert oppenheimer
who was in fact also the person who
figured out
a lot of stuff about black holes and the
collapse of stars and so on
but it's probably most famous uh thing
was
um was that he was the scientific leader
of the manhattan project
so a lot of physicists who i have known
worked on the manhattan project um and
uh
it was um uh was a it was a
was a strange thing to have created
nuclear weapons
um and i think many of them had uh um
it was sort of a it wasn't at all clear
what was going to happen
given that you know one had invented
this technique
for basically uh you know generating
extremely powerful weapons what was
going to happen uh
fortunately uh you know since 1945 these
these weapons haven't been used again
and um
uh there's been surprisingly limited uh
you know there's a limited number of
countries that have the technology and
it's it's a complicated stack of
technology that has to be built to make
a nuclear weapon
um and uh it's a complicated supply
chain
of the kinds of materials you need to do
it and so on
um and uh it's been kept uh
rather limited uh for a surprisingly
long time
uh so in terms of the physicists who
worked on on the project well there were
many
um and and i i knew many of them
um few of them are alive anymore
um the uh the the focus of work in the
u.s
on the uh on the actual atomic bomb was
done at los alamos national lab
in los alamos new mexico um strangely
even when i
i think even when i was first in the us
i think los alamos was a not marked on
maps
town so it was like for all practical
outside purposes it did not exist
um i was for a while a consultant at los
alamos national lab
um in the early 1980s um so that's part
of part of how i got to know a bunch of
these
a bunch of these guys who was still at
los alamos many people had left los
alamos
um i would say oh gosh um
i'm gonna forget lots of people but but
um a couple of notable folks
from there uh one was richard feynman
who i knew quite well who was a
physicist who was particularly
notable for having understood a lot
about quantum electrodynamics
the interactions of of electrons with
photons and so on
his job in the manhattan project he was
a young guy um
uh just um let's see he was
just in graduate school
when when the manhattan project
happened and his job was to run the pool
of human calculators
back in the days of the manhattan
project they didn't have
electronic computers and only primitive
sort of desk calculators and things
and dick feynman's job was when you want
to compute
uh what the um
uh you want to compute characteristics
of what was going to happen in in
in a nuclear explosion for example well
how did you do it well you had to
actually
do computations and that was done by a
pool of people
who had these calculators and would do
it and there would be these different
methods for calculating different things
and dick feinman told me you know one of
the terrible things was
the first uh test of an atomic bomb was
done in the desert in new mexico
in i think 1945 um maybe 1944 but i
think
um and uh they had calculated
one of the one of the potential risks
was i mean because nobody had ever
detonated a nuclear explosion in the
earth's atmosphere
and one of the things that was a sort of
really bad case scenario is
maybe detonating a nuclear weapon in the
earth's atmosphere would ignite the
atmosphere
that is it would just start a reaction
where the whole atmosphere would burn
and that would be sort of super bad news
end of life on earth
you know game over really bad and so
that was one of these cases where you
really had to get the calculation right
and um uh dick fineman was
was his group have been one that was
sort of part of that process of doing
that calculation
and he was like he was very you know
they were like well we think it's going
to come out that it's not going to
ignite this atmosphere
but uh we're going to test this this
thing anyway and
uh fortunately as we know it didn't
ignite the earth's atmosphere and all
was well
but that was the case where the very
high stakes calculation that had to be
made
other people who worked on uh well a lot
of people um
uh dick pimen's thesis advisor john
wheeler was another person
um who worked on on um
okay two people to mention uh edward
teller and stan ulam
um i didn't know i would tell her
particularly although i
i sort of i did meet him and and i've um
uh i know lots of people who knew him he
became
a um a major figure in kind of defense
technology in the u.s
um rather one of the one of the things
is very important actually in the
hydrogen bomb
the the first atomic bomb used in world
war ii was a fission bomb
based on breaking apart uh nuclei of
of uranium and plutonium um the more
powerful bomb that was invented a few
years later was the hydrogen bomb
and um no actually i'm i'm i'm i'm
telling you the wrong history here
it's correct about the hydrogen bomb but
actually the thing i'm going to tell you
is is actually about the original
atomic bomb at los alamos so one of the
key things that you need to do
in making an atomic bomb is you've got
to get a large amount of uranium
into a small volume very quickly and the
way you do that is you detonate an
ordinary explosion with ordinary high
explosives in a kind of a
shell around the uranium and that pushes
the uranium together
and makes and makes the thing get to be
dense enough that it can have a nuclear
uh reaction and nuclear explosion
and so one of the problems is how do you
get all these pieces of uranium pushed
together
sort of quickly enough and you don't
want it so that the thing can kind of
you push it together one way but it
squirts out another way
and so the thing that had to be invented
for that was a thing called the
implosion lens
which is kind of a way of of placing um
uh explosives in a pattern and with
material so that things will be just
pushed together they will just
squash down to be uh so that you get
this sort of spherically symmetric
um implosion rather than something that
squirts out in one direction or another
and so that was um sometime it was
i guess the tele-ulam device was the
thing that was
um sort of the invention that was this
implosion lens and of course
i heard many people say oh really it was
all teller's work oh really it was all
ulam's work
etc as unfortunately tends to happen in
the in the science world
um but uh uh that was that was uh sort
of an important invention
was um uh one of the people involved in
that
um as i say i i did know him uh
in the last few years of his life he
died in 1984 i think
um and um ah
gosh um
well you know it's always so hard when
when
one knows people um
[Music]
yeah he was he was a um
[Music]
what can i say um
[Music]
well one of the things he did he was a
kind of really
particularly a mathematician and you
know for him it was like
can you take a problem and turn it into
an elegant piece of mathematics
particularly a piece of kind of discrete
mathematics that just involves integers
and so on
he did that a bunch of times and one
place he did that
that was um something that sort of
intersected with my own interests
is in these things called cellular
automata which are these sort of simple
programs that are based on just things
with um with black and white squares and
so on and stan ulam
worked on those things and i interacted
with him a bit about those things um
uh late in his life i was right around
the time
i was was working on them in fact i i
once organized
a conference at los alamos in i think
1983 and stan
gave the the after-dinner speech um uh
at that conference um i i have to say i
have to tell you one of these scurrilous
stories i
uh you know which um is kind of a funny
thing
but um right around that time i it was
some article that um
i wrote for the los alamos science
magazine and there was a
a sort of additional add-on which was
which was some
uh uh about the history of cellular
automata a los alamos which is quite
interesting
um and i was like uh i was always
impressed because the the editor of this
magazine
you know had you know that that article
appeared
under her sort of byline and i was
always rather impressed that it seemed
like a very nice piece of
of scientific history okay so now that
was 1983 or something
so now many many many years later i'm
doing history research
for a big book i was writing um and
uh we are interested in getting some
material from the
uh stan ulam archive which is i think in
philadelphia
uh the archive of all his papers um and
the
the person who's working with me sent um
sent a message to the the archivist
there saying you know
uh can we get this information about
this particular thing and the archivist
says oh well actually
there are some letters in the archive
about your boss so of course the person
who was was working on this
for me was like well sure send those to
us too
and um what became clear from those
letters
is that uh stan had been kind of like
the
well you know there's all this
interesting history and um
you know you don't you know these young
people don't know about any of this
history
let's put this history out in in this
magazine and and
but he didn't want us even though he
wrote it he didn't want to sign it
himself it was like let's
you know let's get the editor of the
magazine to sign in so that was that was
kind of a
little bit of a disappointment to me in
terms of the the origin of that because
that actually would have been
interesting to know that that was sort
of stannulam's view of the history
um back um back at that time um anyway i
could i could tell you lots more about
um
uh about these people um
lots lots more um
let's see
ah oh gosh
so many questions here
oh there's one here that i will
you know these questions about history
i'm really happy to talk about these i
love talking about history
um i i have noticed that the older more
typically more interesting the young in
talking about history
and maybe i will do a quite separate um
uh
um session like this um
uh about history and we'd be interested
in some feedback about whether that
would be interesting
um uh
let's see
it's a question from udacio
have you ever considered teaching other
subjects besides math what subjects
you know i have never really taught
anything i was i was briefly a professor
um 30 something years ago and i think i
was
not a um uh
i don't know whether i was a very good
professor um
i i think um one of the problems was
because i had gone through school
without really um um
um uh i didn't really go to very many
classes
from you know i kind of left high school
when i was 16 i kind of went to college
but i didn't have to go to any classes
and didn't
um and i really didn't go to any classes
ever and so then
you know a few years later there i was
as a professor and it's like okay go
teach these classes
but it's like i didn't really know what
to do and um
i think my my kind of high point or low
point was i ended up
um back in 1986 or so ended up
saying i'll teach a class about physics
for non-scientists
and um i i i just had a very
uh strange view i suppose of of what i
should
um uh what i should talk about there
well i think i think people um
uh people seem to enjoy the lectures
although people started coming who
weren't part of the class which is
always
that's a good sign the bad sign was that
that people were like um
uh you know you didn't explain how to do
the homework
and i remember the very last that was in
university of illinois
um and the very first question on my
first sort of homework was
estimate the number of years of corn in
a typical corn field which i thought was
thematically relevant and this was this
was not
appreciated because it was like but
there's no specific procedure for doing
that
and it's like well you have to kind of
think about it and i
you know seems like it's fun to try and
learn how to think about stuff
um but uh anyway my my my days as a
as a as a genuine professor were um
uh were truncated by the fact that i
i decided that um uh it was it was
better to spend my time um
running companies and things um but uh
um the um so i haven't really had much
opportunity to teach anything i in
recent years
i've become much more interested in
these kinds of things i started a few
years ago
um uh particularly where i live in
massachusetts
um teaching some middle school kids and
so on
um about computation i found that pretty
interesting i
i you know it was actually a great way
uh has been a great way for me to learn
more
about how to make our uh wolfram
language and so on easier to use
because it's a case where i actually can
see people um
uh you know using using our products um
and um uh the um uh
that's that's fun and i guess that i've
i've found
you know i just started with this
pandemic kind of doing these um
uh these live streams uh trying to
explain stuff
and and um i hope you guys get something
out of it i know i get something out of
it because i've gotten
i think i've gotten measurably better
you can judge for yourselves
at explaining things as a result of of
um of doing these these live streams
because
because usually in most of the things
that i do it's like people ask me some
question
about um uh you know
the future of fusion energy i see one
here which i'd love to answer but um
the um not gonna have a chance today
and it's like i have to try and think
through you know how do i take the
things i know
and and break them down to the point
where i can actually explain them and
it's
it's been really interesting to um um to
uh
uh
to to sort of learn how to do that
better i see some questions a little bit
about history here
uh someone's commenting on glenn seborg
i i did not know guyn seborg
um the uh the only person who has ever
had an element
named after him while he was still alive
which is a
in recognition of the fact that he was
so involved in uh
in generating new chemical elements by
nuclear processes and so on
um it's a question about uh from luis um
about what do i know about the turret
attore marijuana
um i don't know that much about myrana
um an italian physicist from the 1930s
who uh was a sort of very uh promising
young physicist who disappeared
he got on a boat going to sicily and he
never got off at the other end and
nobody knows what happened to him
uh which is sort of a sad story um and
um uh
the um um but the work that he did
uh has actually become very popular in
recent years
um he was interested in in um um
well kind of things a bit like electrons
but that would have a different uh
way of being um of of operating with
respect to
particularly with respect to spin and
it's become very popular in recent years
so his name is sort of uh
uh these mayarana fermions um
are things that um get heard about um
quite a lot these days
um oh my gosh this question so many
interesting questions here all right
i've got a clearly i've got to do um uh
allocate more time to this unfortunately
i'm
i'm uh supposed to go to something else
in a minute which is actually also a
live stream
about uh more what i actually do for a
living um
designing uh functionality for language
but there's a question here
about music theory and composition um
do i know about dimitri dimitri
timoshenko
is that no i'm not that's not i'm not
saying the name right but but
um a professor at princeton i have
certainly met
um and uh his work on sort of
understanding musical
structures and mapping them into
mathematics great topic
um let's talk about it another time um
and at least i see one question here
where i don't know the i definitively
don't know the answer
it's asking about how it's his
automorphism theorem and i don't know
what that is
so that's a so i'm sorry about that
um and uh um
um all right i think um
um a lot of really interesting
questions here um which i'm going to
have to take up
another time i'm just uh
there's one here from lolit about
neurons
nerve cells in our brains do they
operate uh
quantum mechanically do they operate in
other ways i will say that
my strong suspicion is that quantum
mechanics is not important
in the things that actually affect the
way that we think about stuff
it's probably important in the details
of how
neurons work but almost certainly
the the actual uh electrical processes
that communicate information between
neurons
don't depend in detail on quantum
mechanics um and
they can be uh uh represented without
that but i'd be happy to talk about that
um
um uh another time well i should wrap up
here
for those who might be interested i am
doing another live stream about um i
think i'm talking about
uh working with our team on design for
algebra and calculus functionality and
modern language
for our upcoming version but otherwise i
have to sign off here
and nice to chat with you guys and i
look forward to doing it again
next week all right so
bye from